I recently figured out Arcane's secret
lighting process, and in this video I'm
going to show you exactly how to
recreate it using Blender and DaVinci
Resolve. [music]
>> How screwed up is this place?
I used to say I could fix anything.
>> After an insane amount of requests, I'm
finally doing this. I'm going to walk
you through Arcane's special compositing
workflow, what render passes you need
from your 3D software, [music] and most
importantly, the secret sauce.
And after this video, you'll be
surprised that the style of the bad guys
or even Spider-Verse can also be
recreated [music]
with these techniques.
So with that, let's get into it.
Hi.
Before we get into all the crazy
lighting stuff, let's quickly talk about
the backgrounds. You've probably heard
that the backgrounds in Arcane are fully
painted, and that's true, including the
[music] lighting. So there are no real
3D lights in the scene, but everything
is painted into the textures of the
background. They utilize a technique
called camera projection, where they can
paint the whole background in 2D
and then project it onto 3D geometry.
If you want to learn more about that
process, check out Lightning Boy
Studios' video on that subject. So now
we get to the main section of this
video, [music]
Arcane's lighting process.
If you were to add some lights in
Blender, we get something like this.
[screaming]
Oh, oh, hell, no. Arcane uses a very
different process to add lighting on
their characters. All the magic happens
in compositing. So generally, that means
we export some render passes from
Blender and then combine them in a
compositing software to achieve the
final result. For compositing, you could
really use any compositing software you
like. I truly recommend Blender's
built-in compositor. You could also use
After Effects or Nuke. I personally use
DaVinci Resolve's Fusion tab, just
because I got used to it.
So let's cut to the chase. Let me give
you a quick rundown of the first
technique so you understand where we're
going with this. We have a texture pass
and we have a lighting pass. The texture
pass includes just the colors of our
model and the lighting pass all the pure
lighting information. Now, what we're
going to do is [music] use the
brightness values of the lighting pass
to reveal certain color adjustments. For
example, let's say we have this base
color and now we're going to create a
new color adjustment and let's say we're
just going to make it darker. Now, this
will be our shadow color.
And now by using all the dark parts of
the lighting render, we're going to cut
out the shadow color
and merge it on top of the base color.
So, that way we've added a simple
shadow.
Now, remember this is just the tip of
the iceberg. There is much more to it
than it first seems like, which we'll go
through in this second half of the
video.
But now that you understand the general
idea of what we're going for, let's
start in the beginning step by step.
First of all, which render passes do we
need exactly?
>> For weight to light, it's different.
But it's so simple when you know the
trick.
You say, "Ah,
>> [laughter]
>> so simple."
>> Exactly, it's so simple. [music]
Let's take a look at what they show
right here. They first show a typical
texture pass. [music] All we have to do
here is jump in the shader editor and
directly connect the texture to the
material output. That way you'll only
render out the pure texture [music] of
your model without any lighting.
Then, if we go a bit [music] further, we
can see a lighting pass. Now, there are
many ways to reproduce this,
>> [music]
>> but here is one that is very
beginner-friendly.
For the character, we'll replace all the
materials with a simple diffuse shader.
[music]
No textures applied, just a white base
color. Now, let's add a sunlight.
I increase the strength and the angle
[music] of this sunlight.
Next, we go to the world settings and
turn the strength down to zero.
That way there's no extra light coming
from the sky.
And lastly, let's change one setting in
the render properties.
>> [music]
>> Under light paths, turn the total number
of light bounces down to zero.
So now all that's left in our scene is
the pure direct lighting information.
Let's get back to the making of. If we
go a bit further, we can see another
lighting pass. In this case, [music] the
light comes from behind the character,
slightly angled to the right.
Actually, throughout the whole making
of, we can see the use of these lighting
passes. So what can we do with them? And
why are they so important? Well, let me
show you.
>> [music]
>> This is DaVinci Resolve's Fusion tab,
and it lets you composite with nodes. If
you have no experience with nodes, I'll
leave some links [music] in the
description, but don't worry, it's
actually pretty simple. With shift
space, we can bring in any node we need.
Let's first search for the loader node,
and then just hit
>> [music]
>> enter.
Here we're going to search for our
texture pass, and then just double-click
the image sequence. And now, as you can
see, our texture pass has been imported
[music] as a node. We can preview it by
hitting either one or two for the first
or second viewer.
Now for this tutorial, I'm going to show
you the final composite in the first
viewer,
>> [music]
>> but anytime I want to preview one
specific node, I'll show it in the
second viewer, just so there's no
confusion.
But for now, I'm just going to expand
this.
Let's also bring in our background
render as a lighting reference.
Now you might realize that we don't have
any layers. So how are we supposed to
merge our texture pass on top of our
background?
>> [music]
>> We can do that with a simple merge node.
The merge node is going to be the most
complicated one we're going to cover
today, and even that is really simple.
The yellow socket is the background
input, and the green one is the
foreground input. So, let's drag our
background into the background and our
character into the foreground. Now, if
we preview this merge node by hitting
one, we can see we've just merged our
character on top of our background.
Easy, right?
Now, let's drag it down a little
so we can do all our character
adjustments here before they get merged
on top of the background.
Now, the first thing I'm going to do is
color adjust the character to match the
background better. So, let's hit shift
space and bring in a color corrector
node.
If we hold down shift and drag it in
here, it connects into the stream.
So, now if we follow the stream, we can
see our texture pass gets color
corrected and then it gets merged on top
of the background. So, the color
correction will only affect our
character because the background merging
happens later.
I'm going to make the character slightly
more blue
and more dark.
And now, as you can see, it already fits
the [music] tone much better.
I'm going to call this result the base
color.
So, now to the most complicated, but
also most important part of the whole
process. We're going to add a shadow.
First of all, let's import our lighting
render.
Our lighting render looks like this.
Now, I'm previewing this in the second
viewer, [music] and as you can see, all
the shadows are black and everywhere the
light hits, it gets white.
So, now I'm going to bring in a merge
node once again
and connect it into the stream.
And now, before we connect anything,
let's create our shadow color.
We simply bring in another color
correction node
and plug the base color into that color
correction.
Now, this will be our shadow color, so
let's make it quite a bit darker.
And now, we can connect everything. So,
the base color is already connected into
the yellow background input. Let's
connect our shadow color into the green
foreground input.
Now, into the blue input, we can plug in
a mask that lets us control where the
foreground input appears.
So in this case, we will just plug in
our lighting render.
Now nothing has happened yet, so let's
select the merge node, go into the merge
node settings, and then switch the
channel from alpha to luminance. That
way it actually uses the luminance, aka
the brightness values of our lighting
render.
Now we can see something has changed,
but right now it uses the bright parts
to reveal the shadow color. We want the
exact opposite. We want it to appear in
only the dark parts. So all we have to
do is go back into the merge node and
click apply mask inverted.
So now it uses the dark parts of the
lighting render to reveal our shadow
color.
And as you can see, we've added a simple
shadow.
Here you can play around with any color
adjustment you like to get the exact
look you're going for.
And it's only going to get easier from
here.
So wait, am I saying that all the
shadows we see in Arcane are just the
base texture that was simply color
adjusted to be a bit darker? So no real
3D shadows, but just manually [music]
tweaked values?
Yeah, that's exactly it. Take a look.
Because of this technique, we simplify a
lot of data. We don't get any ambient
occlusion,
specular highlights,
or bounce lighting from the environment.
And that's exactly [music]
the effect we see in Arcane. Now before
moving on to the secret sauce, let's
clear up some stuff. You might be a bit
overwhelmed.
Me as well. You might be a bit
overwhelmed, but let me actually show
you how easy this is.
99% of the shots in Arcane have the
exact same lighting structure.
We start out with the base color, then
we add the shadow, and then the rim
lights. And this three-layer lighting
structure is everywhere. [music]
It's always base color, shadow, rim
lights. Base color, shadow, rim lights.
She she she she. [\h__\h] me. We've just
discussed how to add a shadow, but for
the rim lights, it's actually even more
simple. So, instead of color correcting
our texture pass, we're just going to
bring in a solid [music] color. This
color will be the color of the rim
light. Then we're going to bring in our
rim light render,
>> [music]
>> and again use the brightness values to
cut out the solid color and merge it on
top of the rest.
And this is super quickly done. We're
going to bring in a merge node.
We bring in the rim light render.
And now we need a solid [music] color.
Here it's called the background node.
Don't get confused by the name. It's not
supposed to be a background. [music]
It's literally just a solid color.
I'm going to make this a nice bright
yellow.
Now the solid color goes into the
foreground input, the rim light into the
blue mask input.
And now go into the merge node settings
and change the channel from alpha to
luminance. And as you can see, it
already works.
Now you could also go back to this tab
and change the blending mode to
something like linear dodge, so it
blends in nicer.
And that's it.
Another great thing about this [music]
technique is that we can manipulate our
lighting render however we want to. We
could, for example, add some curves
adjustments to make the lighting more
sharp.
It also kind of flattens the [music]
lighting render and adds another
important layer of the 2D stylized feel.
It's also something we always see in
Arcane. No matter the condition, the
light is mostly super sharp.
Here is another example.
Even here, where the lighting seems to
be very [music] soft, we can clearly see
this hard edge.
But wait, how could that be? How can we
feel soft lighting even though we see
hard edges in the shadows?
Just in case you don't understand the
issue here. Usually soft lighting makes
soft shadows, but that's something we
never see in Arcane. But then again,
when you think of hard lighting, you
wouldn't think of this. Like it feels
soft and we see soft gradients from
light to dark. But then we
simultaneously have hard shadows. So,
what's going on here? Like you know what
I mean? This is super paradoxical.
There must be some kind of
secret sauce.
>> [snorts]
>> I'm breaking into 4K right now.
Oh my god.
Masks.
Let me explain from the beginning.
So, as we know, our lighting render
dictates what the base color is and what
the shadow color is. In this case,
everything black is the shadow color and
everything [music] white is the base
color. And remember, our lighting render
is just a black and white image. Now, we
take a solid black color, cut a part of
it out with a mask,
blur it slightly, and then merge it on
top of the lighting render.
>> [music]
>> This has created a dark spot wherever
our mask is.
Now, that means that our shadow color
will also show up in the part where
we've [music] created that mask.
We can also control how visible this
adjustment is just by [music] changing
the opacity of the mask.
And we can also apply this technique the
other way around. If we merge a white
color on top of our lighting render,
it will essentially bring back our base
color.
That is the basic [music] explanation of
this technique. Now, don't underestimate
this. These masks make a huge
difference.
They [music] allow us to really craft a
whole composition.
This process is super artistically
driven
>> [music]
>> and we literally go, "Ah, let's add a
bit more of the shadow here and ah,
let's slightly bring back the base color
in those parts."
And I get it. You might be skeptical and
this seems super unprofessional to just
draw random masks around the character
and you're just like, "What the hell,
man? This is stupid."
>> Stupid.
>> And yes, you're right. This technique
completely breaks physics and
theoretically doesn't make sense at all.
But here's why it works so surprisingly
well.
>> [music]
>> You see, this isn't a new technique.
It's really commonly used in anime.
There, every shadow you see is
hand-drawn and they rely on these masks
and gradients to make the lighting more
[music] understandable and cinematic.
But now Arcane uses these same
techniques in their 3D animations.
>> [music]
>> That's why they intentionally make their
lighting hard to get that cell-shaded
anime aesthetic.
And on top of that, they use the same
mask and gradient techniques. As far as
I know, this was never seen in 3D
before, at least not to that extent. And
that's what makes Arcane's style
>> [music]
>> so iconic. The lighting is essentially a
combination of 3D rendered lights and 2D
[music] placed masks, which enhances the
concept of mixing 2D and 3D even
further. And that's what makes it look
super surreal and so handcrafted. So,
when you think about it, it isn't stupid
at all. It's freaking genius.
>> [applause]
>> Now, we can't just randomly apply these
masks anywhere we want. So, before we
jump into our project file, let's
quickly analyze some shots from Arcane.
So, as we know, our character is split
into the base color and the shadow
color. So, everywhere we see the base
color, it should generally stay at the
same brightness, right?
Right?
But now, if we take a look at Arcane, we
[music] can see that the more we get
into the shadow side, the more we can
see the base color gets darker.
And that is because we have a very soft
gradient that slowly brings in the
shadow color the further we get away
from the light source.
And here again, the parts where we see
the base color transition more and more
into the shadow color the more we get to
the right side.
So, how do you get this effect? Well, by
using soft masks we can edit our
lighting render to look something like
this.
And as you know, [music] the darker the
lighting render gets the more of the
shadow color gets revealed. So, that way
this hard edge isn't so sudden anymore
and the lighting feels way more soft.
And this is usually how you use these
masks. [music] The initial goal is to
make the lighting more soft and improve
the overall composition.
Here is another example. On the bottom
of the character there's a very soft
gradient that slowly fades in the shadow
color.
And this is actually a super common
gradient since it emulates the natural
ambient light from above.
But sometimes you can use these masks
for other purposes. Like for example
here.
>> [music]
>> In this shot we can see a mask being
used to blend between two different
versions of the base color. One a bit
more red and one a bit more blue.
By creating all these masks manually the
artist literally shapes how they want
the light to be and really guides the
viewers attention to the vocal point
which most often is the face.
And this is also what I meant earlier
with having a super hard shadow but
still getting that soft lighting effect
[music] because with these masks you can
make this hard edge not feel as hard.
And that is the critical effect we need
to achieve the [music] arcane style. So,
let me show you how to do it. So, now
let's finally get into the technical
aspect. It's actually pretty simple.
Just as a reminder, this is the base
color, this is the shadow color and this
is the lighting render which tells the
merge node where to reveal the shadow
color.
>> [music]
>> So, now we can make any changes we want
to this lighting render as long as the
final output connects to this mask
socket.
Let's start with some curves adjustments
to make this edge a bit sharper.
And now let's add a mask. For that, I'm
going to put a merge node
right here.
Now we need a background node, which
gives us a solid black color,
and connect it into the foreground.
And now we're going to take a polygon
node
and connect it into the blue mask input
of the merge node.
For this one, I'm going to create a soft
mask on the bottom of the character.
And as you can see, it fades in the
shadow color.
Let's increase the soft edge slider.
And in the merge node, we can decrease
this blend slider to decrease the
opacity of the mask.
And that is everything you need to know.
So, this is how my final project file
looks like.
If we zoom in,
I've used the mask to blend between two
different base colors.
One is dark and blue, and the other is
more warm and brighter.
Now, for the actual shadow, I'm going to
preview the lighting render so you can
see all the adjustments getting made
before it gets used as a mask.
First, I've added this mask that darkens
the bottom of the character.
Then another one to further define the
shape of the face.
Another one for the hair.
And then I've used a mask that merges a
white color on top, essentially removing
some of the shadow from the face.
And now this is the final result, before
the masks and after.
>> [snorts]
>> Nice. And these techniques are also used
in many other animated pieces. Valorant
and League of Legends cinematics are
basically the exact same.
But even in less similar ones like The
Bad Guys, they make use of these
techniques. For example, the rim lights
look like they were made the exact same
way because they have the same 2D
flattened look to them.
And they also seem to use masks and
gradients to darken certain sections of
their characters.
And even Spider-Verse can be recreated
with these techniques.
We can render out a rim light and
manipulate it in a way so it shows
halftones. And then we use these
brightness values to reveal [music] a
solid color.
And the same thing for the hatching.
>> You got to tell them I can do this.
>> So that's it. The two main techniques
Arcane uses is the lighting render
technique as a base of everything, and
then they manually add masks [music] to
further define how the lighting is
shaped and add way more depth and
composition to the image. And now since
you know the secrets, you can tell that
it's not some mysterious filter, but
actually a super straightforward way of
doing it [music] with the most basic
tools.
>> It's not magical trick. It's just artist
and people who doing beautiful things.
>> And this is exactly what these
techniques are. We can really put in the
colors and values we want, disconnecting
from reality and actually [music]
showing what we want to express.
And that is what makes Arcane so special
and so unbelievably inspiring.
So with that, let's finish this.
Here's a quick way to level up your
shot. I brighten up the eyes to make
them stand out more.
>> [music]
>> If you take a look at Arcane, they also
do this. The eyes should be way darker
in this shot, but they are freaking
glowing.
And now we're fully done with our
character and we just have to do a few
more effects to the background and the
whole image.
First of all, some haze and glows in the
background to add more depth.
And then some final lens effects like
lens blur, [music]
motion blur, chromatic aberration, some
grain, and finally a lens flare, a
vignette, and a little bit of exposure
flicker to add that natural camera feel.
And now, ladies and gentlemen, let me
show you what we've created.
Thank you so much for watching this
video. I hope you've learned something
new.
>> [music]
>> I have some crazy projects planned that
I'm super excited to share with you
guys. So, if you don't want to miss out,
feel free to subscribe. Love you all,
and I'll see you in the next one.
>> [music]
>> Secret sauce.
>> [laughter]
>> [\h__\h] me.